a constant watch is being kept here and
everyone knows it a former place of
protests still packed with police but
something in the atmosphere was
different any sense of dissent quieter
quashed this is the crossroads that's
been the absolute focal point of the
protest really the most highly sensitive
place in the whole of Shanghai the fact
we're even being allowed to film like
this speaks volumes about the confidence
of the authorities it feels like the
crap down here is working
you could almost sense what their orders
had been don't intervene act normal
nothing to see here
but there were signs of the silencing
barriers where yesterday quiet
dissenters had sat blocking any similar
action
and around the corner this a courtyard
temporarily commandeed back up waiting
and ready
[Applause]
the underlying
Greektown cannot contain it indianan
anger at restrictions spilled over to
the streets
efforts to contain remain resolute
The Drudge of zero covert still
dominates lives here tests in the cold
and the wet patience is wearing thin but
even commenting on Covert now feels
sensitive here this woman asked to
remain anonymous
hers might be frustrations universally
felt but some still want to say more
people are much more reluctant to talk
to us tonight but one man did just
approach us he didn't want to be filmed
or identified in any way but he was very
angry he used a swear word to describe
Xi Jinping he said he believes everyone
here sympathizes even the police and he
left us with this mark my words this is
a turning point
that didn't feel like a certainty here
many were just getting on with their
lives that is what most people
ultimately want there were hints some
loosening could be coming but it's
unlikely to be Swift and it's unlikely
to soothe the anger still hidden Helena
Smith Sky News in Shanghai